in the dead of night as families slept  it hit  some were swept away with their homes  others left behind heard neighbors  screaming for help it's bad it really is  we uh  been a fireman almost 27 years and this  is the worst i've ever seen  people unaccounted for  probably 95 of the people in this area  here's lost everything houses cars  animals  it's  it's heartbreaking it really is  unprecedented catastrophic flash  flooding led to mudslides hundreds of  homes have been destroyed whole  communities wiped out we had to swim out  and it was cold it was over my head so  yeah  it was  scary  roads have been washed away  hampering the effort to save lives  tough news is 16 confirmed fatalities  now  and folks that's gonna  it's gonna get a lot higher among those  killed six children but the death toll  may more than double  for now the focus is finding those still  missing  but more rainfall is expected joe pike  sky news